हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है? पहले यह बताइए आप सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है?
बिल्कुल सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है।
ओके। और सबको स्क्रीन विजिबल है? स्क्रीन
में कोई इशू तो नहीं है? बिल्कुल बताओ यह
भी यह चीज बताओ क्योंकि थोड़ा सा नेटवर्क
इशू हो सकता है मेरी साइड से बट इतना नहीं
होगा क्योंकि जितना आप एक्सपेक्टेशन रखोगे
तो बताइए बिल्कुल सब कुछ क्लियर है ओके तो
थैंक यू एवरीवन तो
चलो अच्छी बात है
तो चलिए हम चलते हैं अपने टॉपिक तो आप
लोगों को पता है कि लास्ट क्लास में मैंने
आपको पढ़ाया था एक Windows सर्वर 2019 पर
एक सीटीएफ चैलेंज सॉल्व करके दिखाया था जो
था कि पासवर्ड को Windows कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस
फाइल के अंदर सर्च करना या एंटी एलएम हैस
के बारे में बताया था या एलएम हैसिंग होते
क्या है ये सारी चीज मैंने आपको बताया था
तो
जैसे कि जिन भी स्टूडेंट्स ने मेरे
आर्टिकल्स को सब्सक्राइब किया हुआ है तो
उनको सेम टाइम जैसे आर्टिकल ल्च होता है
नोटिफिकेशन मिल जाती है तो प्रीवियस क्लास
में जो भी कुछ मैंने पढ़ाया था उसके तीन
तीन आर्टिकल्स ल्च हुए हैं। पार्ट वन,
पार्ट टू और उसकी राइट टीम इंगेजमेंट की
जो रिपोर्ट थी प्रोफेशनल रिपोर्ट कैसे अगर
आप कोई असेसमेंट परफॉर्म करते हो ऑफेंसिव
या राइट टीमिंग असेसमेंट तो उसके बाद उसकी
रिपोर्ट कैसे लिखी जाती है वो चीज मैंने
यहां पर एक आर्टिकल में शो किया है। इस
ओनली इस सीटीएफ के बेस पर कि जो सीटीएफ
हमने परफॉर्म किया था Windows सर्वर 2019
में जो भी वल्लनेबिलिटी थी उसके बेस पे
हमें क्या-क्या फाइंडिंग मिली थी
क्या-क्या आर्टिफेक्ट थे वो सारी चीजें
मैंने क्या किया था आप लोगों को उस
रिपोर्ट में लिखा हुआ है और जो पार्ट वन
और पार्ट टू है एक बार जिस भी स्टूडेंट्स
ने अभी तक नहीं देखा है या जिस भी
स्टूडेंट्स ने नहीं पढ़े हैं या जिस भी
स्टूडेंट्स अभी मिस की है ये सारी चीजें
प्लीज जाइए और इस आर्टिकल्स को पढ़िए
क्योंकि जो चीज मैंने आप लोगों को पढ़ाया
है उससे ज्यादा इन आर्टिकल्स में लिखा हुआ
है। उससे ज्यादा लिखा हुआ है। अगर मैं मैं
आपको आर्टिकल्स का लिंक प्रोवाइड कर देता
हूं ताकि आप लोगों को डाउट ना रहे।
चलिए ये रहा। तो आर्टिकल्स मैंने शेयर कर
दिया है। तो आप इस पे जाके पढ़ सकते हो।
इसके पार्ट वन और पार्ट टू आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे। जैसे ये रहा ये कंप्लीट
आर्टिकल्स मैंने आपको दिखाया है। ये रहा।
ये आपका कंप्लीट आर्ट आर्टिकल्स है।
ये रहा ये रहा। उसके बाद आगे नीचे चलोगे।
यह तो बिल्कुल पार्ट वन तो आपको आईडिया है
कि कुछ भी नहीं है। तो, पार्ट टू में
मैंने कुछ और भी मेथड इसके अंदर इनवॉल्व
किए हैं। जैसे कि आप देखोगे यह दिस इज़ द
पार्ट टू। तो, पार्ट टू देखोगे, तो पार्ट
टू में मैंने बिल्कुल डिटेल में बताया है
कि इनिशियल एक्सेस लेने के बाद आपको जो
अनअटेंडेड
फाइल है, अटेंडेड फाइल है, वह कैसे फाइंड
आउट करनी है। कितने तरीके से आप फाइंड आउट
कर सकते हो। देखो अनअटेंडल फाइल को आपको
देखना है और यह सारी डायरेक्टरी जो
रिस्पांसिबल्स होती हैं जहां-जहां पर आपको
ये फाइल देखने को मिल सकती है। यह सारी
चीजें इस आर्टिकल्स में यहां पर इनवॉल्व
की गई है। स्क्रीनशॉट अटैच किए गए हैं।
फ्लैग की इंफॉर्मेशन दी गई है। सीएमडी और
पावर सेल की कमांड यहां पर शो की गई है।
मतलब जो चीज मैंने पढ़ाई नहीं थी उससे भी
ज्यादा इसमें आपको डिटेल्स में शो किया
गया है। मतलब हर एक स्टेप को काफी ब्रीफ
काफी डिटेल्स में एक्सप्लेन किया गया है।
एस पर योर एक्सपेक्टेशन जो आप एक्सपेक्ट
करते हो हमारी एकडमी से वह सारी चीजें
इसके अंदर हैं। बाकी वीडियो के अंदर तो
डिटेल में की बताया ही बताया गया है। उसके
बाद देखोगे यह आपका एक और आर्टिकल्स है।
रेड टीम पार्ट वन था सॉरी मैं गो बैक हम
पीछे चलते हैं और यह आर्टिकल भी मैं आपको
शेयर कर देता हूं कि वैसे तो आप लोगों को
आर्टिकल मिल जाएंगे। आपको बिल्कुल भी
चिंता करने की जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि एक
आर्टिकल्स पे जाओगे तो बाकी आर्टिकल सारे
के सारे आप लोगों को मिल जाएंगे। तो अभी
तक जिसको लगता है कि हमने आर्टिकल्स पढ़ने
हैं, नोट्स चाहिए या हमें सर आर्टिकल्स
अच्छे लग रहे हैं और ऐसे मिलते रहे तो आप
इसको एक काम कीजिए सब्सक्राइब भी कर लीजिए
और ईमेल आपको सेम टाइम मिल जाएगा। यह
आर्टिकल देखिए असेसमेंट रिपोर्ट कैसे आपको
रिपोर्ट लिखनी है। क्या-क्या फाइंडिंग थी?
हर एक चीज को मैंने यहां पर डिटेल्स में
मेंशन किया हुआ है। आप भी आप अपने
रिपोर्ट्स में इस तरीके के डिटेल्स मेंशन
कर सकते हो। जस्ट ये एक सीटीएफ की राइट अप
है जो आप
क्या अगर प्रैक्टिस के तौर पर यूज़ कर सकते
हो कि जब भी आप क्या करते हो कोई भी
सीटीएफ परफॉर्म करते हो अगर उसके ऊपर आपको
कोई भी आर्टिकल्स लिखना हो तो या कोई भी
रिपोर्ट लिखनी है आपको कैसे आप वह
रिपोर्ट्स लिख सकते हो यह वो रिपोर्ट है
तो मैं आपको जस्ट इन्फॉर्म कर रहा हूं कि
यह सारी चीजें भी मैंने आप लोगों के लिए
इंटरनेट पर फ्री में ओपन सोर्स रख दी गई
है। आप कभी भी यह जाके पढ़ सकते हो।
बाकी लास्ट क्लास में शायद आप लोगों का
कोई भी डाउट नहीं रहा होगा। लास्ट क्लास
से रिलेटेड किसी का कोई भी डाउट नहीं बचा
होगा। तो यह मैं उम्मीद कर सकता हूं। तो
प्लीज एक बार मुझे यह बता दीजिए कि लास्ट
क्लास में जो भी कुछ मैंने आप लोगों को
पढ़ाया था सबके डाउट क्लियर है? अगर किसी
का कोई भी डाउट है तो मुझे बताइए। अदरवाइज
हम अपने सेशन को कंटिन्यू करते हैं। कोई
डाउट तो नहीं होगा किसी का?
सबके डाउट क्लियर है? आई आई होप
बिल्कुल क्लियर है
तो वेरी गुड तो देखिए
देखिए बग बाउंट तो मैं नहीं स्टार्ट
करवाऊंगा बिकॉज़ बग बाउंटी अगर नितेश सर
करवाते हैं तो मैं उनको ओवराइड नहीं
करूंगा क्योंकि बग बाउंट उन्होंने भी काफी
अच्छे से बताया है तो मुझे शायद दोबारा
उसको कवर करने की जरूरत नहीं होनी चाहिए
क्योंकि आप एक स्टूडेंट हो आपके लिए मैं
अगर बग माउंट दोबारा भी कवर करता हूं तो
बाकी जो स्टूडेंट्स बचे हुए हैं उनमें
क्या प्रॉब्लम है कि वह बाद में चैनल को
वो करेंगे कि नहीं सर आप लोगों के पास
कंटेंट नहीं है बस वही रिपीटेशन में लेके
आते रहते हो तो यह चीज हम नहीं करने वाले
लेकिन बग बाउंटज आपके लिए ऑलरेडी बहुत
डिटेल्स में पढ़ाई गई है अराउंड आपकी 55
या 50 प्लस जो सीरीज अवेलेबल है अगर आप
उसको दिन में दो दो सीरीज भी दो लेक्चर्स
भी आप देखोगे आपके लिए एनफ है।
तो एक काम करते हैं। फिर हम सेशन को
स्टार्ट करें।
देखिए आज मैं आपको
पास द हैश अटैक के बारे में बताने वाला
हूं। यह अटैक होता क्या है? कैसे काम करता
है? यह सारी चीजें मैं आपको बताने वाला
हूं। बिल्कुल
स्टार्टिंग से। मतलब कि इसकी इंट्रोडक्शन
पार्ट के साथ-साथ कि यह ऐसे कैसे परफॉर्म
किया जाता है प्रैक्टिकली भी यह चीज मैं
आपको बताने वाला हूं। तो आज जो हम सीटीएफ
लैब लेने वाले हैं शायद उस लैब को हम पहले
सॉल्व भी कर चुके हैं या नहीं की होगी वो
इतनी बेसिक लैब है। यहां पर मैं मानता हूं
कि जितने भी स्टूडेंट्स आज क्लास में आए
हैं 90% उसको सॉल्व कर चुके होंगे और या
उसका वॉक थ्रू आप देखोगे तो आपको आईडिया
मिल जाएगा। आप वह कर चुकेगे बिकॉज़ इट इज
वेरी वेरी बेसिक लैब। उस लैब में कुछ है
नहीं। बट आपको पता है सचिन सर उसको पढ़ाने
वाले हैं। तो डेफिनेटली इतनी एक चीज तो
श्योर है कि वो चीज वॉक थ्रू में भी नहीं
होगी। आपके जो राइट अप्स प्रोवाइड किए गए
होंगे ना वह भी आपको पता है कि उसमें भी
वह आप चीजें आपको देखने को नहीं मिलेगी।
मिलेगी। यह चीज आपको बिल्कुल क्लियर पता
है। क्यों? इसका कारण सबको पता है। क्यों
नहीं मिलेगी? क्योंकि
मेरा जो तरीके हैं मैं वह तरीके
खुद के यूज करता हूं जो राइटअप के तरीके
यूज़ नहीं करता और जो मैं कांसेप्ट पढ़ाता
हूं वो कांसेप्ट ही उसमें यूज़ करने वाला
हूं और आज खुद ही देख लेना आपको आप वो जो
लैब मैं आपको पढ़ाने वाला हूं वो लैब का जो
वॉक थ्रू अगर आप देखना चाहोगे किसी भी
मीडियम आर्टिकल किसी भी आर्टिकल से तो
आपको पता चल जाएगा कि वो क्या है और मैंने
क्या पढ़ाया है टोटली डिफर डिफरेंट वे
क्योंकि हम कोशिश करते हैं कि किसी भी लैब
के थ्रू सॉल्व करना हमारा पर्पस नहीं
होता। हमारा पर्पस क्या होता है? आपको
सिखाना। ओके?
तो थैंक यू। आपका नाम बता दीजिए मुझे। तो
अच्छा लगा कि आप लोगों ने यह इंफॉर्मेशन
शेयर की। मुझे जस्ट एक थोड़ा सा टाइम
दीजिए। मुझे जस्ट अपने नोट्स को ओपन करने
दीजिए। दीजिए आप लोगों के लिए। ओके जस्ट
नोट्स को ओपन करने दीजिए। मैं फिर उसके
बाद क्लास को कंटिन्यू करता हूं।
ओके
तो अच्छी बात है तो आपने अच्छा रिव्यु
दिया है तो मैं यहां पर कमेंट नहीं करूंगा
बिकॉज़ यह तो आप जो स्टूडेंट्स हो आपके पास
बहुत बड़ी पावर होती है। पावर में क्या
होता है कि आप लोग क्या कर सकते हो? किसी
को भी जज कर सकते हो। क्योंकि टोटली आप पर
डिपेंड करता है कि आप चाहते क्या हो? आपकी
डिमांड क्या है? और आप पहले क्या है
रिसर्च नहीं करते। उनके बारे में रिव्यूज
नहीं लेते। आप डायरेक्टली क्या है पेमेंट
आप क्या करते हो कि जो इंटरनेट पे किसी ने
उसकी हाइप क्रिएट कर दी। उस चीज़ को फॉलो
करते हो। देन उसके बाद आप रिग्रेट करते
हो। बट पहले आपको एटलीस्ट रिव्यूज या कुछ
चीजें आपको पता होनी चाहिए। देन ओनली आप
अपने पैसे किसी चीज के लिए डालिए। मैं तो
यही बोलूंगा क्योंकि
उससे क्या है कि आपको भी फायदा होगा और घर
वालों को भी फायदा होगा और हम तो हम कोशिश
करते हैं कि ज्यादा से ज्यादा मैं नितेश
सर कि आप लोगों के ज्यादा पैसे वेस्ट ना
हो। अगर आप किसी चीज के लिए पैसे वेस्ट कर
भी रहे हो या किसी चीज के लिए आप पैसे लगा
भी रहे हो तो वह आपके काम आने चाहिए। आपको
उसका बाद में रिग्रेट ना हो।
तो थैंक यू हैकर्स एडीएफ तो अच्छी बात है
आपने शेयर कीजिए। अगर आप ऐसे ही शेयर करते
रहेंगे तो सचिन सर डेफिनेटली आपके लिए
ऐसे-ऐसे लेक्चर्स लेके आएंगे जो आपके
एक्सपेक्टेशन से बहुत ज्यादा पड़े दूर हैं
जो आप सोचोगे कि नहीं यह तो उम्मीद ही से
बाहर था कि ऐसा भी कोई लेक्चर्स आने वाला
था। जस्ट मुझे जस्ट 1 मिनट का टाइम दीजिए।
चलिए काम बन गया। नोट्स हमारे ओपन हो गए
हैं। तो थैंक यू मेरे साथ बने रहने के
लिए। तो मैं एक काम करता हूं। अभी ट्राई
हैक पर हम चलते हैं वॉक थ्रू और हम यह लैब
लगभग हर स्टूडेंट सॉल्व कर चुका था। काफी
इजी लैब है। यह वो हम पहले भी सॉल्व कर
चुके हैं। बट सबको पता है कि हम क्या करने
वाले हैं। हमारा मेन मोटो क्या है। मैं इस
लैब को स्टार्ट करता हूं और अपना
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन आप लोगों के
सामने शो करता हूं कि हम क्या करने वाले
हैं एग्जजेक्टली।
देखिए मैं यह बोलूंगा कि यह वीडियो से
डायरेक्टली शुरू करोगे तो कोई भी प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है। अगर आपको पहले से नॉलेज है। अगर
आपको पहले से नॉलेज नहीं है तो प्रॉब्लम
हो सकती है क्योंकि आपको चीजें समझ में
नहीं आएंगी कि क्या चल रहा है क्या नहीं
चल रहा। बट हां मैं आपको रिकमेंड यह
करूंगा कि आप वीक डेज में स्टार्टिंग से
स्टार्ट कीजिए और जब भी लाइव क्लास आती है
उसको मिस मत कीजिए क्योंकि करंट में क्या
चल रहा है और प्रीवियसली आप क्या देख रहे
हो बहुत अच्छे से कंपेयर कर पाओगे क्योंकि
उससे आपको पता चलेगा कि आपकी रिक्वायरमेंट
क्या थी और मुझे अभी और क्या सीखना है और
क्या नहीं सीखना वो सारी चीजें आपको
क्लियर हो जाएंगे। चलिए मैं एक काम करता
हूं अपनी मशीन को ओपन करते हैं।
चलिए ओके
सब ये सॉल्व कर चुके होंगे पहले कितने लोग
इसको सॉल्व कर चुके हैं इस लैब को बताओ
पहले
कितने लोग इसको सॉल्व कर चुके हैं जल्दी
से बताइए चैट में कितने लोग इस चीज को
सॉल्व कर चुके हैं पहले
कितने स्टूडेंट्स बस एक ही स्टूडेंट है जो
इसको सॉल्व कर चुका है या और भी हैं
सॉल्व कर लिया ना? तो चलो आज एक और नया
तरीका दिखाता हूं मैं आपको। मतलब हो सकता
है आप उससे भी सॉल्व कर चुके होगे। मैं यह
नहीं बोल रहा। बट चलिए हम एक काम करते
हैं। हम अपने तरीके से सॉल्व करते हैं। आप
सबको पता है सचिन सर का क्या तरीका होता
है।
और शायद लास्ट के क्लास तक बने रहना।
लास्ट में क्लास तक बने रहना और मुझे
बताना कि क्या मेरा तरीका सही था? आपका
तरीके से बेटर था या आपका तरीका बेटर था।
ओके
ओके बहुत अच्छी बात जिसजिसने सॉल्व किया
है। चलो मेरे साथ बने रहिए और देखिए।
चलो सूडो स्विच यूजर करते हैं और
सक्सेसफुली अभी हम अपने ट्राई हैक के
सर्वर से जुड़ चुके हैं और इफ कॉन्फिग
करते हैं तो हम ट्राई हैक के सर्वर से
जुड़ चुके हैं। यह हमारा IPपी एड्रेस है
192.168.130.64।
चलिए, हम अपने टारगेट मशीन के IP एड्रेस
को भी देखते हैं। यह हमारे टारगेट मशीन का
IPपी एड्रेस है। तो, सबको पता है जब भी
हमारे पास IP एड्रेस होता है, हमें क्या
करना होता है? सबको पता है। तो, हम सबसे
पहले क्या करते हैं कि वह लाइव है या नहीं
लाइव है। यह चीज जानने की हम कोशिश करते
हैं। तो, 10.48.137.9
हमारा टारगेट IPपी एड्रेस है। तो, सबसे
पहले हमने इसको पिन किया। पिन करते ही
हमें पता चला कि जो हमारा होस्ट है, वह
लाइव है। मतलब एक्टिव है। हमें इस पेन
टेस्ट करना है। तो, चलिए हम स्टार्ट करते
हैं। सबसे पहले जो हमारा टास्क होता है
एनुमिशन, स्कैनिंग या इनेशन गैदरिंग। जब
हमारे पास आईपी एड्रेस है तो इसका मतलब
हमने इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर लिया है। और
जो हमारी जो डीएचई की सीरीज है उसने सबसे
डे वन से एक चीज पे फोकस किया है कि हम
पहले पेन टेस्ट ऐसे कर रहे हैं कि वी आर
कनेक्ट वी आर द पार्ट ऑफ दैट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
कि हम उस नेटवर्क का पार्ट हैं। तो इंटरनल
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग कर रहे हैं। हम
बेसिकली वो है। अभी तक हमने एक्सटर्नली
नहीं किया कि मतलब हमारे पास कोई भी
एक्सेस नहीं है। हमारे पास कोई भी
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है। जैसे कि हम वेब
एप्लीकेशनेशंस की करते हैं। उसके बाद हम
इंटरनल पेन टेस्टिंग पे शिफ्ट करते हैं।
क्योंकि हम एक कनेक्शन बनाते हैं। लेकिन
यहां पर ऐसा नहीं है। ऑर्गेनाइजेशनंस हमें
हायर करती है। हम हमें हायर करने के बाद
हमें एक टास्क देती है कि चलो आपको इस
नेटवर्क की पेन टेस्ट करनी है। तो पेन
टेस्टिंग हम कैसे करेंगे जूनियर लेवल पर।
यह हमारा प्राइमरी मोटो है। तो चलिए हम
देखते हैं फिर इसको। तो सबसे पहले हम क्या
करते हैं? एंड में परफॉर्म करते हैं। मैं
आपको शायद नीचे दिखाई नहीं दे रहा होगा।
मैं इसको क्लियर कर देता हूं स्क्रीन को।
स्क्रीन को क्लियर कर देता हूं शायद। अब
आप सबको फोंट साइज सही दिखाई दे रहा है या
थोड़ा सा बड़ा करना बताइए मुझे। फोंट साइज
सही है या बड़ा करना बताओ।
साउंड साइज थोड़ा सा बड़ा करना या सही है
बताओ।
ओके सही है।
बिल्कुल सही है। बताओ
ओके ठीक है। तो चलिए एक काम करते हैं हम
अभी करते हैं एन मैप परफॉर्म करते हैं।
जैसे एन मैप हम परफॉर्म करेंगे। और एक और
चीज बता देता हूं आप लोगों को कि यह
आर्टिकल्स भी आपको
जल्दी देखने को मिलेगा विद इन वन और टू
डेज और यह जो मैं पढ़ाता हूं उससे ज्यादा
डीप में मिलेगा। मतलब जहां पर ज्यादा डीप
में जाने की कोशिश है, जहां पर डीप में
जाना चाहिए, जहां पर मुझे एक्सप्लोर करना
है ज्यादा, उस एक्सप्लोर के साथ यह आपको
देखने को मिलेगा आर्टिकल्स। तो इसलिए
आर्टिकल्स को भी 100% रीड करना क्योंकि
वहां पर भी काफी इनेटिव इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
देखने को मिल सकती है। कोई टिप्स या कोई
ट्रिक्स जो शायद आपने एक्सपेक्ट नहीं की
हो या हो सकता है एक्सपेक्ट की हो तो आपको
मार्क डाउन करने की जरूरत है। तो हम करते
हैं एन मैप हफन
पीएन ये पीएन ऑप्शन किस प्रकार से यूज़
किया जाता है तो बताओ बताइए
ओके साइज इनक्रीज मैं कर देता हूं ये रहा
एनम मैप हफन पीए हफन सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन हफन वर्बोसिटी का हमने बढ़ा दिया
मैं सारे पोर्ट को स्कैन करने वाला हूं और
उसके बाद मैं IP एड्रेस इंसर्ट कर रहा
हूं। IP एड्रेस मेरा क्या था? ये रहा
10.48.137.9
ये हमारा IP एड्रेस है। और जैसे ही हम
क्या करते हैं? हिट एंटर करते हैं, हम
देखते हैं कि इस मशीन के ऊपर हमें
क्या-क्या देखने को मिलता है।
बिल्कुल हम क्या कर रहे हैं अभी?
बिल्कुल सही बात।
तो अभी थोड़ा सा वेट करना पड़ेगा क्योंकि
मेरे केस में अभी प्रॉब्लम यह है कि मैं
अभी जो क्लासेस ले रहा हूं वह मोबाइल डाटा
से क्लास ले रहा हूं जिससे प्रॉब्लम यह है
कि स्पीड का थोड़ा सा इशू है क्योंकि
वाई-फाई से मैं कनेक्टेड नहीं हूं। मैं
अवेलेबल नहीं हूं एट होम कहीं पर बाहर से
मैं आपके लिए क्लास ऑपरेट कर रहा हूं। दैट
इज व्हाई कि मोबाइल डाटा से मैं आपकी
क्लासेस ले रहा हूं। जिसकी वजह से जो
लैब्स की जो सॉल्व करने की फ्रीक्वेंसी है
थोड़ी सी स्लो डाउन होगी। बिकॉज़ इंटरनेट
फास्ट नहीं है हमारे पास। जब तक इंटरनेट
फास्ट नहीं होगा तब तक हम कुछ भी नहीं कर
सकते। यह सबको पता है।
तो देखिए अभी टोटल 18 स्टूडेंट्स हैं। 18
से 10 स्टूडेंट रह गए। तो लोगों को लगता
है कि यह लैब हम सॉल्व कर चुके हैं। तो
क्यों इस क्लास को अटेंड करें? यह हमारे
लिए वेस्टेज ऑफ टाइम होगा।
क्लास के स्टार्टिंग में आते हैं।
स्टार्टिंग में आने के बाद क्या सोचते हैं
कि बोला ओके यह टॉपिक है। मैं पढ़ चुका
हूं। स्किप इट। तो इट्स ओके। मैं हमें अब
मैं बोलता हूं आप लोगों को स्किप कीजिए।
एक दिन ऐसा आएगा एक ऐसी क्लास स्टार्ट हो
जाएगी बीच में। आप उसको हमेशा के लिए
स्किप ही करके रह जाओगे कि ओके यह क्या कर
दिया मैंने? यह मुझसे कितनी बड़ी गलती हो
गई। मुझे नहीं करना चाहिए था। यह आप एक
दिन 100% रिग्रेट करोगे। जहां पर आप पैसे
देकर रिग्रेट करते हो या फ्री में आप
रिग्रेट करोगे क्योंकि सडनली मैं कब कौन
सी चीज आपको पढ़ा दूंगा आपको आईडिया ही
नहीं है गाइस
और मेरी क्लास में मैं अभी भी आपको क्या
डेडिकेटली पढ़ा रहा हूं कि 11 स्टूडेंट
आते हैं और
फिर भी मैं मोटिवेशन रखता हूं अपने पास से
कि कोई नहीं स्टूडेंट्स भर जाएंगे कोई इशू
नहीं है तभी थोड़ा सा टाइम लगेगा। अगर आज
सॉल्व नहीं हुई लैब आज अगर पेंडिंग रह गई
तो एक काम करेंगे इस क्लास को कंटिन्यू कल
फिर कर लेंगे। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। बैक
टू बैक दो क्लास ले लेंगे। कोई इशू नहीं
होगा।
देखो अभी और भी स्टूडेंट्स कम हो रहे हैं।
मतलब कि
देखो
आई होप मुझे यह मैं यह समझता हूं कि आप
लोगों को वह जगह पसंद आती है कि जहां पर
जादू चाहिए जहां पर दूसरे चैनल्स पे क्या
होता है। आज हमने यह कर दिया जस्ट वहां कि
आप देखना कि कितने स्टूडेंट ज्वाइन करते
हैं। दे आर हैप्पी एंड वी दे आर ऑल द
हैकर्स।
तो मोस्ट वेलकम दोज़ टाइप ऑफ हैकर्स दोज़
टाइप ऑफ पेंटेस्टर्स। मैं भी उनका दिल से
स्वागत करता हूं।
कोई नेटवर्क के साथ इशू तो नहीं है किसी
के भी नेटवर्क के साथ
यह बहुत समय लेने वाला है मुझे पता है अभी
इट विल टेक टाइम लॉट ऑफ टाइम्स
मैं इसको एक काम कर देता हूं। थोड़ा सा
फास्ट कर देता हूं कि इतने सभी पोर्ट को
हम स्कैन नहीं करते।
यस बिल्कुल बोलो। आपका कोई जो भी सवाल है
मुझसे पूछ सकते हो।
यस यू कैन आस्क नाउ
तो एक काम करो मैं स्किप करके इसको थोड़ा
सा फास्ट करता हूं तो हम करते हैं एन मैप
स्कैन हफन स्किप पोर्ट डिस्कवरी सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन उसके बाद हम परफॉर्म करते
हैं
ओनली सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन प्लस में IP
एड्रेस
जल्दी हो जाएगा क्योंकि वहां पर हमारी
वबिलिटी मिल जाएगी।
यू कैन आस्क ब्रो कोई इशू नहीं है।
देखो सीसीटीवी की पेन टेस्ट या सिक्योरिटी
टेस्टिंग के लिए दो ही तरीके हैं। या तो
उसका फिजिकल एक्सेस होना चाहिए आपके पास
और फिजिकल एक्सेस या अदरवाइज क्या होना
चाहिए जो सीसीटीवीज हैं सीसीटीवी के केस
में क्या होता है अगर वह आईपी पर है आईपी
इन द सेंस कि अगर वह इंटरनेट से कनेक्टेड
है तो इंटरनेट से कनेक्टेड में सेम कहानी
आती है क्योंकि वह आई ओटी डिवाइस के अंदर
आता है। सीसीटीवीज हो गए या बाकी जो आपकी
टीवी हो गए आपके स्मार्ट डिवाइसेस हो गए
वह सारे आई ओटीज हैकिंग में आते हैं। तो
उसके लिए अगर आपको सीखना है तो उस चीज के
लिए आपको आई ओटीस की पेन टेस्टिंग सीखनी
पड़ेंगी। इंटरनेट ऑफ थिंग वाली चीजें जो
जितने भी आजकल जो भी स्मार्ट डिवाइसेस हैं
जितने भी स्मार्ट डिवाइसेस के साथ आप
कम्युनिकेट करते हो कि हमारे इंटरनेट से
कनेक्टेड है यह है वो है तो सब आप आईओटीज
के अंदर आते हैं। तो अगर इन सब की पेन
टेस्टिंग करनी है आपको या इन सब से
रिलेटेड कुछ भी करना है तो उसके लिए आपको
सीखना पड़ेगा आई ओटीज की पेन टेस्टिंग।
इसमें पता नहीं कितना ओके बस इट इज नियर
बाय टू फिनिश
तब तक के लिए आप मुझसे सवाल पूछ सकते हो
बाकी और किसी को सवाल पूछना है
मे बी आपने गलत फाइल डाउनलोड कर ली है तो
मैं आपको पर डे वन से एक ही चीज बोलता हूं
ना कि आप लोग सही चीजें डाउनलोड कर कीजिए
वह सही रहेगा आप लोगों के लिए
इट विल टेक लॉट ऑफ टाइम्स बिकॉज़ शाम का
टाइम है तो ट्राई हैक सर्वर्स भी बिजी हैं
और दे विल
रिसोंड वेरी स्लोली एंड माय नेटवर्क अभी
बैंड बजी पड़ी है।
एन मैप स्कैनिंग में यह हालत है। पता नहीं
अभी आगे क्या होगा।
आई एक और चैटिपिट को छोड़ के खुद से
Google पे भी देखो जहां पर आपके बहुत सारे
लोगों ने ऐसा चीजें फेस की होंगी तो वह
बता देंगे आपको कहीं ना कहीं आपको हेल्प
फाइल मिल जाएगी कि क्या-क्या इशू हो सकता
है।
यस
आप देख सकते हो विदाउट एनी नॉलेज। बट बात
वही है कि विदाउट एनी नॉलेज आप सीरीज तो
स्टार्ट कर लोगे लेकिन चीजें आपको सीखनी
पड़ेंगी कि आपको अगर कोई नॉलेज है ही
नहीं। अब नॉलेज पे डिपेंड करता है कि आपको
हो सकता है कि आपके जो पीसीस हैं, आपके
कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं, उनकी नॉलेज है आपको
फंडामेंटल्स तो इट्स ओके। आप सीख सकते हो।
आपने अगर 12th तक चीजें कंप्यूटरटर्स में
सीखी हैं, थोड़ा बहुत प्रोग्रामिंग थोड़ा
बहुत आईडिया है कि कैसी चीजें काम करती
हैं। तो वो चीजें बेटर है। अगर आप बिल्कुल
ही ब्लैंक हो, ब्लैंक पेपर हो, आपको कोई
भी आईडिया नहीं है तो उस केस में क्या
होगा? उस केस में आपको यही चीज है कि यहां
से स्टार्ट जरूर कर लोगे। बट आपको ज्यादा
मेहनत करनी पड़ेगी। ज्यादा मेहनत करने के
साथ-साथ आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा? एक्स्ट्रा
रिसर्च करनी पड़ेगी अपने ऊपर।
क्या यार लाइव स्ट्रीमिंग प्लस में वही
चीजें दोनों चीजों ने यही प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट
कर दी कि अभी
एक एन मैप स्कैनिंग इतना टाइम लगा रही है।
बाकी स्टूडेंट्स भी अपने डाउट्स पूछ सकते
हो। यह वीडियोस तो सही होगी ना? कोई
बफरिंग वगैरह तो नहीं हो रही होगी क्लास
में। सब लोग बताइए। किसी को बफरिंग या कुछ
तो इशू देखने को नहीं मिल रहे होंगे।
बाकी आपको सब कुछ बिल्कुल क्लियर दिखाई दे
रहा होगा। सब कुछ सही से।
प्रॉब्लम विद वही है अपने
ट्राई ह में सर्वर के साथ प्रॉब्लम है।
फिर दे आर वेरी वेरीरी स्लो।
कोई हम स्पीड चेक करना चाहे तो वह भी कर
सकते हैं। देखते हैं कि क्या
काफी अच्छी स्पीड है। कोई इशू नहीं है। तो
ट्राई हैक के सर्वर की
ऐसा कोई इशू ट्राई में सर्वर का इशू है तो
मेरी तो कोई प्रॉब्लम ही नहीं है।
चलो फिर देखते हैं क्या इशू हो सकता है।
कैसे सॉल्व होगा।
आई विल आल्सो कवर द वाईफाई पेन टेस्टिंग
डोंट वरी मैं कवर करूंगा इस कोर्स
आई होप आई थिंक मैं एक काम करता हूं इसको
कंट्रोल सी करता हूं और क्लियर कर दे हम
प्रॉब्लम इधर नहीं है। प्रॉब्लम है उधर
इसको टर्मिनेट करते हैं। फिर से
ऑन करते हैं मशीन को।
आज हम सीटीएफ परफॉर्म ही नहीं कर पाएंगे।
मुझे लगता नहीं कि हम कर पाएंगे नहीं कर
पाएंगे।
यस हाय हेलो
मुझे एक चीज बताइए आप लोग YouTube पे अपनी
जो यूजर आईडीज के अलग-अलग या यूनिक नाम रख
के जो
कितना अच्छा लगता है आप लोगों को
से सच में आप लोग वह बन जाओगे।
बीटेक इज बेटर देन बीसीए।
बिकॉज़ बीटेक हम बात करें तो
डिमांड की तो जिसकी ज्यादा
डिमांड की बात करें जिसकी पावरफुल रिजम
में बनेगी वो बीटेक ही होता है। बीसीए तब
करते हैं जब आपके पास कोई ऑप्शन नहीं
होता।
चलो पिंग हो रहा है हमारी मशीन एन मैप
करते हैं। उसके बाद हम सर्विस वर्जन
डिटेक्शन करते हैं। कंट्रोल शिफ्ट वी बाकी
इसके साथ हम कुछ नहीं करने वाले। देखते
हैं कि कौन-कौन से पोर्स ओपन है, कौन-कौन
से पोर्स ओपन नहीं है।
रोड मैप ऑलरेडी हमारी
डेफ़ोनिक्स एकडमी पर आपको देखने को मिल
जाएगा। एक क्लास होगी नितेश सर की जो रोड
मैप प्रॉपर रोड मैप वहां पर बताया गया है
कि वह चीज आप वहां से देख सकते हो।
डिग्री तो कुछ भी करने के लिए बहुत ज्यादा
जरूरी है।
मुझे लगता नहीं कि आज यह कुछ कर पाएंगी।
पिंग ही होते रह जाएगा हमारी मशीन का।
यस ओके तो ये सारे पोर्स ओपन हमारी मशीन
के ऊपर 135 139 445 3389 सॉरी 3389 तो
मुझे यह बताइए
तो कौन-कौन से इंटरेस्टिंग पोर्ट्स हमारे
लिए ये रहा फॉर ये रहा ये सारे पोर्ट्स
आपके ओपन है तो कौन-कौन से इंटरेस्टिंग
पोर्ट हो सकते हैं हमारे लिए जिन पे हम
अपने फर्दर एनुमरेशन कर सकते हैं तो
कौन-कौन से
तो देखिए देखिए हम एक काम करते हैं अभी
थोड़ी सी और इनके ऊपर एलिमिनेशन परफॉर्म
करते हैं। तो वो क्या है? एन मैप देन उसके
बाद हम परफॉर्म करते हैं
डिफॉल्ट स्क्रिप्ट स्कैन डिफ़ॉल्ट
स्क्रिप्ट स्कैन और उसके बाद वलनेबल
जो वनेबिलिटी स्कैन है तो डिफ़ॉल्ट वनेबल
स्क्रीन मतलब जो डिफ़ॉल्ट वनेबिलिटी चेक
करने की स्क्रीन होती है जो वन स्क्रिप्ट
होती है वो हम चेक करते हैं कि स्क्रिप्ट
वन उसके बाद हम चेक करते हैं किन-किन से
पोर्ट्स पे पोर्ट हमारे पास कौन-कौन से
हैं पोर्ट नंबर वन है 135
139 44 45 और इंटरेस्टिंग पो्स हमारे लिए
क्या है? 3389
बाकी भी कोर्स हमारे लिए इंटरेस्टिंग है।
15 160
16 152 153 1515 1660 ये हमारे पास है।
देन उसके बाद हमारा क्या है? IP एड्रेस है
10.48.59
159.43
हम इन पे क्या करते हैं? एक तो
वनेबिलिटी स्कैन करते हैं। जो डिफ़ॉल्ट जो
वनेबिलिटी होती है वो स्कैन करते हैं
क्योंकि बेसिक सीटीएफ है तो हमारा इसके
अंदर कुछ ना कुछ मिलने के चांसेस हैं। तो
चलिए यहां पर हम डिफ़ॉल्ट वनबिलिटी स्कैन
करते हैं कि जो ऑलरेडी जो वनबिलिटी
अवेलेबल्स है क्या वो पैच हो रखी है इस
मशीन के ऊपर या पैच नहीं हो रखी। और एक और
चीज देखते हैं कि कौन सी मशीन एक तो श्योर
है कि Windows मशीन है और क्योंकि Windows
के प्रोटोकॉल्स यहां पर देखने को मिल रहे
हैं आपको और इससे एक चीज श्योर होगी
Windows मशीन है। बाकी Windows का कौन सा
वर्जन है? यहां पर हमें हिंट मिल रहा है
कि 7 टू 10 मतलब से भी हो सकता है और 10
भी हो सकता है। तो वह चीज हम अभी कंफर्म
कर लेंगे। उसके लिए हमें बिल्कुल भी चिंता
करने की जरूरत नहीं है।
आज मुझे मैं जो टॉपिक आपको कवर करवाने की
सोच रहा हूं शायद पता नहीं करवा पाऊंगा
नहीं करवा पाऊंगा बट आई विल ट्राई माय
बेस्ट
अब एक और काम करनी है एक साथ पैरेलल तो
काम नहीं होंगे इसमें
यस 89
चलिए तो यहां पर देखते हैं और क्या
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली
यहां पर कुछ की खास इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं यहां
पर और स्क्रिप्ट रिजल्ट में देखो एसएमबी
वनेबल एमएस 1054 फॉल्स
वनेबल सीवी एंटी स्टेटस एक्सेस डिनाइड
एसएमबी एमएस 1061 एंटी एक्सेस डिनाइड एमएस
S10
वनेबल MS 17010 वनेबल रिमोट कोड
एग्जीक्यूशन वनेबिलिटी इन माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
एसएमबी वर्जन वन सर्वर ओके वनेबल यह इसकी
सीवीआईडी है रिस्क फैक्टर हाई है।
क्रिटिकल रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन वनेबिलिटी
है। बस यह चीज़ हमें देखने को मिल गई है।
तो यह क्या है? आपकी आपको पता है इटरनल
ब्लू वनबिलिटी है। तो एक काम करते हैं। यह
चीज तो हमें पता चल गया बट आपको पता है कि
एसएमबी ऑन है तो हमें पता है कि एसएमबी
एनुमिशन परफॉर्म करना होता है कि हमें हम
यह देख सकते हैं कि कौन सा प्रोटोकॉल यूज़
हो रहा है। थोड़ा क्रॉस चेक भी कर सकते
हैं कि ये रिजल्ट सही है या गलत है। तो
उसके लिए हम क्या कर सकते हैं? एन मैप मैं
एक काम करता हूं अभी इसको क्लियर तो नहीं
करूंगा। तो मैं रन करता हूं एन मैप उसके
बाद हफन हफन स्क्रिप्ट उसके बाद स्क्रिप्ट
हम चेक कर रहे हैं पहले एसएमबी
प्रोटोकॉल्स
एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल्स हफन पोर्ट नंबर 445
उसके बाद आपका IP एड्रेस जो है हमारा यह
रहा 10 48.159.135
और इसको हम कर देते हैं हिट एंटर और चेक
करते हैं कि कौन सा वर्जन यूज़ हो रहा है
SMB
यह एसएमबी का वर्जन यूज़ यह कौन सा
प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ हो रहा है? एनtएलएम SMB V1
मतलब डेंजरस इसने शो कर दिया क्योंकि
एसएमबी वर्जन कौन सा वन यूज़ कर रहे हैं।
मतलब वहां पर वनरेबिलिटी है बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट
क्योंकि लास्ट क्लास में हमने देखा था कि
एसएमबी वर्जन टू या थ्री था। तो क्या
ज्यादा सिक्योर था और इतनी चीजें हमें
वहां पर देखने को नहीं मिली थी। तो यहां
पर एक और चीज करते हैं कि हम ओएस डिस्कवरी
भी करते हैं। इसके अंदर एक और स्क्रिप्ट
रन कर करके देख सकते हैं। एसएमबी एन मैप
हफन हफन स्क्रिप्ट उसके बाद हम एसएमबी हफन
ओएस डिस्कवरी
ओएस डिस्कवरी आई थिंक यह होगा। एसएमb ओs
डिस्कवरी हफन पोर्ट 445 और यह हमारा IPपी
एड्रेस है। हिट एंटर करते हैं। तो यहां पर
और इनेशन देखते हैं कि ओके
Windows 7 प्रोफेशन मतलब Windows 7 Pro यह
उसका सर्विस पैक वन और पीसी का नाम है जोन
पीसी नेट बायस पीसी का नाम यह है वर्क
बुक्स ऑन सो सिस्टम टाइम मतलब इंफॉर्मेशन
हमारे पास मिल रही है। और उसके बाद हम
क्या कर सकते हैं? एसएमबी का सिक्योरिटी
मोड और चेक करते हैं कि एनोनिमस एक्सेस
अलाउड है या नहीं है। यह सारी चीजें भी
स्क्रिप्ट के थ्रू भी पता चल जाएगा। बाकी
भी एनोनिमस एक्सेस हम फिजिकली भी चेक
करेंगे। तो एक और स्क्रिप्ट होती है सब
क्योंकि ये स्क्रिप्ट देखो आपको पता है कि
मैं जब एसएमबी एनरेशन सिखाया था आप लोगों
को ये सारी चीजें मैंने आपको एक्सप्लेन की
थी वन बाय वन सारी चीजें डिटेल में बताई
थी कुछ भी नया नहीं है आपके लिए और पहले
भी हम देख सकते हैं सिक्योरिटी मोड उसके
बाद हफन पोर्ट
यह रहा हिट एंटर तो सिक्योरिटी मोड क्या
है अकाउंट यूज्ड गैस अकाउंट मतलब ओके
ऑथेंटिकेशन लेवल यूजर है। चैलेंज साइनिंग
डेंजर्स बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट। चलो यह सारी चीजें
हमें हमसे क्लियर हो रही है। तो एक और काम
करते हैं हम। अभी एनोनिमस चेक करते हैं कि
एनोनिमस एक्सेस अलाउड है या नहीं है इसके
ऊपर। तो एसएमबी क्लाइंट का हम यूज़ करते
हैं। उसके बाद हफन कैपिटल एल स्लश उसके
बाद यह रहा और कैपिटल हफन एन क्योंकि
लास्ट क्लास में देख चुके हैं हम और हिट
एंटर। ओके। एनोनिमस लॉग इन सक्सेसफुल
मतलब एनोनिमस एक्सेस अलाउड है बट
रिकनेक्टिंग विद एसएमबी वन फॉर वर्क ग्रुप
लिस्टिंग डू कनेक्ट सो ऑन सो या कुछ एरर
है एंटी स्टेटस रिसोर्सेज डेम नॉट फाउंड
मतलब एनोनिमस एक्सेस लॉग इन है बट हम शेयर
लिस्ट नहीं कर सकते और साथ में जो डोमेनस
और जो ग्रुप्स हैं उनके भी जो शेयर्स हैं
वह भी लिस्ट नहीं कर सकते। यहां पर देखो
एरर को समझना बहुत जरूरी है। अगर आप इस
एरर को डायरेक्टली कट कॉपी पेस्ट अगर चाहे
जीपीटी के अंदर भी रखोगे तो आपको आईडिया
मिल जाएगा कि इस पर्टिकुलर एरर का कारण
क्या हो सकता है जिससे क्या होता है? आपकी
स्ट्रांग प्रैक्टिस बढ़ेगी। बट मैं आपको
समझा देता हूं कि एनोनिमस लॉग इन अलाउड
है। बल्कि जब आपने hन l यूज़ किया तो ये दो
टाइप्स की चीजें फाइंड आउट करता है। एक तो
क्या है कि आपके शेयर्स फाइंड आउट करता है
कि इसके ऊपर कौन-कौन से शेयर्स हैं। बट
यहां पर क्या है कि आप शेयर को एक्सेस
नहीं कर सकते। आपको अनोनिमस लॉग इन करने
की परमिशन है। दूसरा क्या होता है कि जब
आपने देखा होगा कि जो आपका नेटवर्क टैब
होता है जो आप देखोगे यह रहा फाइल मैनेजर
के अंदर यह नेटवर्क टैब है। तो यहां पर जब
हम क्लिक करेंगे तो इसके अंदर क्या है कि
कई बार हम शेयर फोल्डर क्रिएट करते हैं और
वह दूसरे पीसी के साथ एक्सेस करते हैं। तो
वो इंफॉर्मेशन कौन-कौन से पीसी उस शेयर को
एक्सेस कर रहे हैं? वह इनेशन भी आप क्या
कर सकते हो? यहां पर फैच कर सकते हो इसके
अंदर। इसीलिए हफन एल का यूज़ किया गया।
लेकिन यहां पर क्या वो चीजें अलाउड नहीं
है। इसीलिए ये एरर आपको देखने को मिल रही
है। तो आई होप कि ये चीज आपको क्लियर हो
गई होगी। उसके बाद हम एक और चीज चेक करते
हैं कि क्रैक मैप एक्सैक्ट क्रैक मैप
एग्जैक्ट जो सीएमई है उसका यूज़ करते हैं
क्योंकि काफी इंपॉर्टेंट टूल है वो एसएमबी
देन हम यूज़ करते हैं आईपी एड्रेस अह करने
के हम एनोनिमस एक्सेस चेक करें। हमें पता
ही है ना तो एनएस एक्सेस चेक करने के लिए
चलो शिफ्ट वी यूजरनेम हम एम्प्टी रख देते
हैं पासवर्ड एम्प्टी रख देते हैं और चेक
करते हैं कि एनोनिमस एक्सेस तो अलाउड ही
है तो देख लेते हैं यहां पर क्या ये ओके
मतलब एनोनिमस एक्सेस अलाउड है यहां पर
प्लस साइन है यहां पर लॉग इन हो गया तो एक
और काम करते हैं हम यहां पर शेयर के लिस्ट
आउट करने की कोशिश करते हैं कि कौन-कौन से
शेयर्स हैं इसके अंदर तो कई मल्टीपल्स
टूल्स हम यूज़ करते हैं तो उससे हमें एक
कंफर्मेशन मिलता है कि जो इंफॉर्मेशन हमें
मिल रही है वह इंफॉर्मेशन सही है। तो हिट
एंटर किया। यहां देखिए कि यहां पर शेयर जब
एक्सेस करने की कोशिश कर रहे हो तो आपको
स्टेटस एक्सेस डिनाइड मतलब आप शेयर एक्सेस
करने की आपके पास परमिशंस नहीं है। आप यह
नहीं कर सकते। चलो कोई नहीं दूसरे टूल्स
हैं उनको यूज़ करके देख सकते हैं कि उनमें
कुछ खासियत तो नहीं है। तो हम आरपीसी
क्लाइंट का यूज करते हैं। आरसीपीसी
क्लाइंट को यूज़ करके देखते हैं। आरपीसी
क्लाइंट हफन कैपिटल यू और यह रहा एम्प्टी
पासवर्ड। देन उसके बाद हम रखते हैं हफन
कैपिटल एन। उसके बाद आईपी एड्रेस हमारा
वही एंटर। यह देखिए यहां पर कनेक्शन तो बन
गया बट हम चेक करते हैं कुछ इसकी कमांड
होती है। एनम
डोम यूज़र्स
डोम एनm डोम यूजर यूज़र्स हिट एंटर किया तो
देखते हैं कि ही इज़ एबल टू फाइंड आउट और
नॉट कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन हमें यहां पर देखने को
मिलती है। नो एंटी एक्सेस डिनाइड मतलब
आपको एक्सेस डिनाइड है। एक और चीज क्यूरी
डिस्क
डिस्पिन इनफो
डिस्प इनफो ठीक है तो होती है क्यूरी
डिस्प
इनफो डोंट वरी ये सारी चीजें हैं कि हर एक
टूल्स के बारे में धीरे-धीरे उस आर्टिकल्स
में मेरे पास एक चेक ऑफ लिस्ट होगी और जो
लिस्ट हो सकता है कि आपको इन फ्यूचर्स एक
साथ देखने को मिलेगी। कुछ ना कुछ इस पे भी
चल रहा है आपके लिए। यहां पे भी एक्सेस
डिनाइड है। कोई नहीं। एलएसए क्यूरी देखते
हैं।
एलएसए क्यूरी यह भी एक्सेस डिनाइड। मतलब
हमें एक्सेस नहीं है इसके ऊपर तो कोई
फायदा नहीं है लॉग इन करने का। नेक्स्ट एक
और चीज क्या कर सकते हैं हम? आरपीसी
क्लाइंट हमने चेक करके देख लिया। उसके बाद
हम एक काम कर सकते हैं कि जो एक एसएमबी
क्लाइंट
यह चीज यह बताओ कि कितने लोगों ने यह चीज
ट्राई की थी। इस तरीके से इस इस सीटीएफ को
कभी ट्राई किया था इस तरीके से किसने भी
ट्राई किया था बताओ शायद किसी ने भी नहीं
किया होगा
जिसने भी सॉल्व किया है किस-किस ने ऐसे
ट्राई किया था आईपीसी शेयर को हम एक्सेस
करने की कोशिश करते हैं जो कि जो कॉमन
होता है सबके लिए क्या इसके लिए परमिशंस
है हमारे पास
किस-किस ने किया था बताओ किसी ने भी किया
हो तो नहीं किया होगा यहां पे देखो हम
एनोनिमस एक्सेस लॉग इन हो गया है एलएस
करते हैं तो एंटी एक्सेस डिनाइड मतलब कि
ओके ओके। तो हमारे पास एक ही ऑप्शन बचा कि
हम शेयर की लिस्ट आउट नहीं कर पा रहे।
शेयर को हम फाइंड आउट नहीं कर पा रहे कि
कौन-कौन से शेयर्स हैं इसके अंदर। हमारे
पास एक ही ऑप्शन है कि हम जो वनेबिलिटी है
एमए 17 वन है वही एक्सप्लइट करनी होगी। तो
चलिए भाई हम उसको एक्सप्लइट करना स्टार्ट
करते हैं क्योंकि हमने बहुत हाथ पैर मारे।
हमने पता करने की कोशिश की कि एनोनिमस
एक्शन एनोनिमस एक्सेस इनेबल है या डिसेबल
है। हमें पता चला एनोनिमस एक्सेस इनेबल्स
है। तो उससे हमने ट्राई करने की कोशिश की।
तो भाई हम कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर ही
नहीं पा रहे बिकॉज़ हर एक चीज स्ट्रिक्टली
मेंटेन की गई है। वहां पर सिक्योरिटी
मेंटेन की गई है। हमें एक्सेस अलाउड ही
नहीं है। उसके लिए हमें क्या करना होगा?
या तो उसको ब्रूट पोस्ट करना पड़ेगा।
पासवर्ड फाइंड आउट करने पड़ेंगे। तो अभी
हमारे पास ऑप्शन तो यही बच गया कि हम क्या
करें कि हमें करना होगा कि चलो अब हमें
पता चला कि यहां पर इसके अंदर वनेबिलिटी
हो सकती है कौन सी एसएमबी वर्जन वन है तो
इथर ब्लू जो वबिलिटी इटरनल ब्लू वनबिलिटी
है अगर उस वनबिलिटी को हम ट्राई करके देख
लेते हैं क्योंकि हमें तो एट एट ऑफ द एंड
हमें बेनिफिट होना चाहिए तो हमें तो
एक्सेस करना है तो चलो हम करते हैं तो
सबसे पहले हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं अभी उसके
लिए एमएसएफ कंसोल का मेटा स्प्लॉट का ताकि
हमारा काम थोड़ा और आसान हो जाए मैनुअल के
बजाय तो आप मैनुअल ट्राई करना तो आपके लिए
और भी अच्छा रहेगा बेस्ट प्रैक्टिस होगी
तो हम क्या करते हैं अभी एक उसके लिए सबसे
पहले पोस्ट ग्री एसक्यूएल सर्विस स्टार्ट
करनी है हम पोस्ट
स्टार्ट किया हमने तो सर्विस स्टार्ट कर
दी पोस्ट ग्रसक्यूएल की उसके बाद हम
एमएसएफ कंसोल को स्टार्ट करेंगे
हिट एंटर सो दैट
किसी ने ट्राई नहीं किया था। तो देखो मैं
आपको बताया था ना कि भले ही आप लोग यह
सीटीएफ सॉल्व कर चुके हो बट मेरा तरीका
अलग है और मेरे तरीके से आप देखोगे तो
आपको बहुत कुछ सीखने को मिलेगा। तो चलो
मेरा तरीका देखिए यहां पर और आपको सीखने
को डेफिनेटली मिलेगा। तो अभी हम क्या करते
हैं? क्लियर कर देते हैं स्क्रीन को।
स्क्रीन को क्लियर हो गई तो
क्लियर हो गई। अभी हम क्या करते हैं? सर्च
करते हैं
MS 17
ड10
हिट एंटर और जब हमने इसको सर्च किया तो हम
ज्यादा इंटरेस्टेड किसमें हैं? देखो यहां
पर एक तो यह है एक्सप्लइट Windows SMB यह
रहा 2014 एवरेज यस
इटरनल ब्लू एसएमबी रिमोट Windows कर्नल
पूल कर्नल ओके यह है उसके बाद क्या है
इटरनल रोमांस इटरनल सर्वे ये हमारे काम का
नहीं है उसके बाद देखो एसएमबी रिमोट हमें
मतलब इसमें इंटरेस्ट है इसके अंदर तो चलिए
हम इसको क्या करते हैं अभी कॉपी करने के
बाद हम इसका यूज़ जीरो करेंगे तो यूज़ जैसे
हम ज़ीरो लिखेंगे तो पहले वाला जो
मॉड्यूल्स है वह यूज़ में आ जाएगा।
Windows, SMB, MS 17, इटरनल, ब्लू। तो,
अभी हमें कौन-कौन से ऑप्शंस इसके अंदर सेट
करने हैं वो भी चीज हम देखते हैं। तो
ऑप्शंस के अंदर चलते हैं हम। जैसे ही
ऑप्शंस के अंदर चलते हैं, तो देखिए कि
यहां पर लिखा हुआ है आर होस्ट हमें सेट
करना पड़ेगा। टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस आर पोर्ट
ऑलरेडी सेट है। एस एसएमबी डोमेन ऑप्शनल
है। रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। एसएमबी पासवर्ड
यूज़र्स की अभी रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। नो
वेरीफाई टू टू ऑलरेडी सेट है। और यहां पर
Windows X864 मीटर पर रिवर्स डीसी भी है।
तो अभी एक काम करते हैं हम सेल के लिए
ट्राई करते हैं। थोड़ा इसको चेंज करते हैं
पेलोड को। तो एक काम करते हैं हम सेट आर
होस्ट।
उसके बाद यह हमारा टारगेट आईपी है
10.48.159.135
हिट एंटर सेट एल होस्ट क्योंकि लोकल होस्ट
भी हमें सेट करना पड़ेगा। कौन सा? ट्यून
ज़ीरो मतलब जो हमारा IPपी एड्रेस कौन सा
है? अह ओपन वीपीए के थ्रू हमें जो ट्राई
हैक में सर्वर का IPपी एड्रेस जो मिला है,
यह भी हो गया। उसके बाद अगर हम चेक करें,
हमें सेट पेलोड करना है। हमें पेलोड चेंज
करना है। सेट पेलोड विंडोज
उसके 64 सेल उसके बाद रिवर्स टीसीp हो गया
हमारा हिट एंटर। अगर हम फिर से क्रॉस चेक
करते हैं। अभी इसको क्रॉस चेक करेंगे तो
देखिए ध्यान से। तो ये रहा हम हमने सेट कर
लिया। सेल रिवर्स टीसीp और सारे ऑप्शन सेट
हमारे। देखो आर रोस्ट सेट हो गया। आर
पोर्ट ऑलरेडी सेट है। देन उसके बाद एल
होस्ट हमारा सेट है। एल पोर्ट हमारा सेट
है। और अगर IPपी एड्रेस देखना चाहते हो
इनका तो IPपी एड्रेस भी देख सकते हैं कि
क्रॉस चेक करने के लिए तो इफ कॉन्फ़िग
ये रहा 192.168.130.64
और हम इसको क्रॉस चेक कर सकते हैं।
192.168.130.64
और सिंपली हम इसको क्या कर देंगे? रन।
जैसे इसको हम रन करते हैं तो देखना कि
हमें सेल एक्सेस मिल जाएगा।
चलिए तो शायद आप देख पा रहे हो कि हमें
सेल एक्सेस मिल गया। तो अगर अभी हमें सेल
एक्सेस मिल भी गया तो नेक्स्ट स्टेप हमारा
क्या होता है? नेक्स्ट स्टेप हमारा क्या
होता है? सेल एक्सेस मिलने के बाद हमें
चीज क्रॉस चेक करनी होती है। हमारा लोकल
एनुमरेशन करना होता है कि भैया हमें
एक्सेस किस टाइप का मिला है? तो चलो हु एम
आई हु एम आई करेंगे तो हमने देखा कि एंटी
अथॉरिटी सिस्टम
एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम ओके मतलब मुझे सिस्टम
लेवल का एक्सेस मिल गया। कोई नहीं हम एक
काम करते हैं सिस्टम इनफो चेक करते हैं कि
ये हमें क्या मिल रहा है। तो इसमें देखिए
यह देखोगे आप तो होस्ट नेम zone पीसी
Microsoft Windows 7 प्रोफेशनल यह उसका
सर्विस वर्जन सर्विस पैक बिल्ड नंबर उसके
बाद आप देखोगे यहां पर यह इसका प्रोडक्ट
आईडी है उसके बाद यह यहां आप देखो ओके ओके
ओके नाउ देखो Windows 32
ये सारी इनेशन आपको देखने को मिल रही है।
चलिए एक और चीज हम देखते हैं कि और
क्या-क्या हमें देखने को मिल रहा है। और
क्या-क्या चीजें हमें
तो और क्या चेक कर सकते हैं हम? और चेक कर
सकते हैं ग्रुप की इंफॉर्मेशन। हु एम आई
और ग्रुप्स।
ग्रुप्स की इंफॉर्मेशन हम चेक करते हैं।
तो यह हमारे ग्रुप्स की इंफॉर्मेशन है।
ग्रुप नेम मैंडेटरी ओके ग्रुप ग्रुप की
इंफॉर्मेशन ये मैंडेटरी सिस्टम
मैंडेटरी लेवल मैंडेटरी लेवल एमएल
थोड़ा अजीब नहीं है। देखो
हमारे पास एंटी अथॉरिटी है सिस्टम लेवल
एक्सेस और
टोकन कौन सा हमारा एमएल मीडियम इंटीग्रिटी
लेवल
क्या सच में हमारा जो एक्सेस है वह एंटी
अथॉरिटी है या यह भी रिस्ट्रिक्टेड है
बताइए सच में क्योंकि अगर मैं इसको क्रॉस
चेक भी करता हूं चलो हु एम आई उसके बाद
ग्रुप्स
ग्रुप्स उसके बाद एक कमांड होती थी ना
फाइंड कमांड का हम यूज़ करते थे। उसके बाद
लेबल उसके बाद यह चेक करें। हम लेबल चेक
करते थे तो मीडियम इंटीग्रिटी लेवल हमारे
पास है। हाई क्यों नहीं है? क्योंकि
सिस्टम के पास तो हाई इंटीग्रिटी लेवल
होना चाहिए। बताइए सिस्टम के पास तो हाई
इंटीग्रिटी लेवल होता है। तो हमारे पास तो
ऐसा नहीं है। और एक और चीज अगर हम चेक
करें तो प्रिलजेस देखते हैं। क्रॉस चेक
करने के लिए हु एम आई। उसके बाद प्रव्यू
यह क्या है? प्रिलजेस भी हमारे पास नहीं
है। मतलब एंटी अथॉरिटी अगर हम होस्ट नेम
भी चेक करते हैं तो देखो होस्ट नेम हमारा
क्या है?
मतलब लोकल एनिमेशन किया हमें। होस्ट नेम
जोन पीसी है और
गेट यूआईडी अगर हम चेक करें। गेट यूआईडी
इसका नहीं होगा। हम उसके लिए होते हैं और
हु एम आई हमने चेक किया तो हम एंटी
अथॉरिटी सिस्टम है। एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम
तो क्या आप मुझे बताइए मेरे पास क्या
प्रजेस रिस्ट्रिक्टेड होने चाहिए? नहीं
होने चाहिए। क्या मेरे पास इंटीग्रिटी
लेवल एमएल होगा? नहीं होगा। मतलब इससे एक
ही चीज है कि हमारे पास वो एक्सेस नहीं है
जो होने चाहिए। अगर मैं नेट यूज़ नेट
यूज़र्स की मुझे जरूरत ही नहीं है। मतलब
कुछ तो गड़बड़ है भाई। यहां पर ऐसे नहीं
है कि आपको डायरेक्ट सब कुछ मिल गया।
बताइए गड़बड़ है ना? और अगर एक काम करते
हैं कि लास्ट क्लास में हमने क्या किया
था? एक और चीज चेक की थी कि लास्ट क्लास
थी जो कि हमने कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस के अंदर
पासवर्ड ढूंढने की कोशिश की थी अनअटेंडेड।
तो हां, चलो, हम उसके लिए कमांड भी यूज़
करके देख लें। डायरेक्टरी सी के अंदर एंड
यह रहा। यह एस उसके बाद बी स्टार मार्क।
देखते हैं कि हमें कुछ इस टाइप की कुछ
चीजें मिलेंग एक्सML फाइल क्या हो सकता है
पहले वाली वनेबिलिटी है भी या नहीं इसमें
जो ऑब्वियसली है नहीं हट अनअटेंड
स्टार एस्ट्रिक्स
डॉट एक्सML देखते हैं कि हमें इसमें कुछ
मिल रहा है नहीं मिल रहा और देखो इट विल
टेक टाइम बट यह चीज आप भी फाइंड आउट करने
की कोशिश कर सकते हो कि इसमें कुछ मिल रहा
है या नहीं मिल रहा बट मुझे तो लगता कि
इसमें है कुछ ऐसे
पर जो चीज हम फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश
करें तो वह तो नहीं मिल रही इसमें
और ही कुछ शो कर रहा है।
क्योंकि इसमें है नहीं वैसे आप फाइंड आउट
करोगे।
मजा आ रहा है क्लास में गाइज बताओ।
आई थिंक इट वाज़ टोटली अनएक्सेक्टेड वर्जन
ऑफ ब्लू सीटीएफ सॉल्यूशन।
शायद यह एक्सपेक्ट मतलब आप सोचो ना कि आप
कितने तरीके से उसको सॉल्व कर सकते हो। आप
सारे ट्रिक्स यूज़ कर सकते हो फ्री लैब से
बट आप कभी यूज़ करते ही नहीं। जस्ट आप
सॉल्व करने के लिए वर्क थ्रो यूज़ करते हो
और वही सेम आप उसमें कॉपी पेस्ट करके बस
हो गया आपका लैब्स कंप्लीट। मैं इसको अभी
स्टॉप कर रहा हूं क्योंकि बहुत लंबी लिस्ट
है। मतलब कितना आप सर्च करोगे इसमें बहुत
ज्यादा हो जाएगा। अबाउट सेशन यस ओके सेशन
अबाउट हो गया आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट तो इसको
हम फिर से रन कर लेंगे कोई इशू नहीं है तो
ये सारी चीजें हमने चेक की थी बट आप सबको
पता चल गया कि हमें सिस्टम लेवल एक्सेस है
बट देखते हैं कि अभी नेक्स्ट स्टेप हमारा
क्या होना चाहिए देखो हमारे पास इनिशियल
एक्सेस हो गया हमें इनिशियल एक्सेस मिल भी
गया अब इनिशियल एक्सेस के बाद भी मुझे यह
बताओ कि हमें नेक्स्ट स्टे अब हम क्या
करेंगे नेक्स्ट स्टेप करेंगे हम अपने आज
का जो हमारा जो इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक है
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग या हम बात करें जो
डंपिंग क्रेडेंशियल या डंपिंग पासवर्ड
हैसिस की बात करते हैं हम जो अपने पासवर्ड
हैस को हम डंप करेंगे ओके जहां क्या
करेंगे हम पासवर्ड हैस को डंप करने की
कोशिश करेंगे ओके क्योंकि ये डंप करना
क्यों जरूरी है? क्यों डंप करना चाहिए?
क्यों नहीं करना चाहिए? ये सारी चीजें अभी
हम देखने वाले हैं। ओके? ये चीजें अभी हम
देखने वाले हैं। क्यों इतनीेंस है इसकी?
कौन क्या इसकीेंस नहीं है यह चीजें आई
थिंक कि अभी हमारा कनेक्शन ही लॉस हो गया
इससे
ओके ओके चलो चलो चलो चलो
एक बार और कनेक्शन बन जाए बस ओके हमें
सक्सेसफुली एक्सेस मिल गया फिर से हम हु
एम आई करके देख लेते हैं तो हमें एक्सेस
मिल गया थ्री ओपन इट्स ओके कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है तो अभी हम क्या करते हैं कि एक
टॉपिक है हमारा कि हैस को डंप कैसे करते
हैं तो किसी को कोई आईडिया है कि मुझे अगर
हैस को डंप डंप करना है तो मैं कैसे डंप
कर सकता हूं? अगर मुझे अपने हैश को डंप
करना है तो कोई टूल्स अवेलेबल्स हैं, कोई
टेक्निक्स अवेलेबल्स हैं। कोई भी मुझे
बताना चाहेगा।
उसके लिए एक टूल यूज़ करते हैं हम। एक हम
बात करते हैं यहां पर। ओके। यह रहा।
मैं इसको एक काम करता हूं। इसको स्मॉल कर
देता हूं स्क्रीन के लिए ताकि आपको
स्क्रीन पर दिखाई दे और मैं इसको
अरे यार
और भी फों्ट बढ़ा देता हूं मैं एक काम कर
लेता हूं।
ठीक है? तो एक काम करते इसको मिनिमाइज
करते हैं हम अभी के लिए। इसको मिनिमाइज
करते हैं। अभी हम समझने टॉपिक तो आज जो हम
टॉपिक देखने वाले हैं, वह आपका है
मिमी कैड्स के बारे में।
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग वाया मिमी कैच। ठीक
है?
मिमी कैच से हम क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग
देखेंगे। ठीक है? हम मिनी कैच के थ्रू हम
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग देखने वाले हैं। तो
सबसे पहले हम मिमीज के बारे में जानते हैं
कि मिमी कैच होता क्या है? जो मिमीज है
आपका Windows का क्या है? एक पोस्ट
एक्सप्लइटेशन टूल है। क्या है? मिमीज आपका
एक पोस्ट एक्सप्लइटेशन टूल है जिसको
बेंजीमिन डिले ने डेवलप किया था। किसने
इसको डेवलप किया था? इसको डेवलप किया था।
डेवलप बाय बेंजीमिन।
किसके द्वारा? बेंजीमिन।
बेंजीमिन।
डेलपी
सॉरी फॉर द प्रोनाउंसिएशन बेंजीमिन डेलपी
के द्वारा इसको डेवलप किया गया था और यह
डेवलप किया गया था। अब यह क्या करता है?
बेंजीमिन क्या करता है कि Windows की
मेमोरी के अंदर जितने भी जो सेंसिटिव
इनेशन होती है जो क्योंकि इसके अंदर
क्या-क्या हो सकता है? बहुत सारी सेंसिटिव
इनेशन जैसे आपके क्लियर टेक्स्ट पासवर्ड
हो गए, पासवर्ड हैज़ हो गए, आपके करब
स्टीकर्स हो गई। इन सारी चीजों को क्या कह
सकता है? यह एक्सट्रैक्ट करके आपको शो कर
सकता है। यह इसकी पावर है। यह इसकी पावर
है। अब आपको सबको पता है कि जो Windows के
अंदर एक सेम डेटाबेस है। सेम डेटाबेस क्या
है? सेम डेटाबेस के अंदर क्या आपके जितने
भी यूज़र्स हैं, जो लोकल यूज़र्स अकाउंट है,
उनके पासवर्ड हैज़ की फॉर्म में स्टोर होता
है। मतलब जब भी क्या होता है? जब भी कोई
यूजर लॉगिन करता है, लॉगिन करने के बाद
उसका जो पासवर्ड है, वह क्लियर टेक्स्ट की
बजाय क्या होता है? वो हैज़ की फॉर्म में
सेम डेटाबेस के अंदर स्टोर होता है।
मिमिकच क्या करता है? मिमीज जो एलसास
प्रोसेस होती है। मिमिकच क्या करता है कि
जो एलसास प्रोसेस होती है
जो एलsस प्रोसेस है मैं आपको बता देता
हूं।
एलsस.exc
हेलs क्या होता है आपका? हेलsस होता है
आपका लोकल सिक्योरिटी अथॉरिटी सब सिस्टम
सर्विस। यह वो प्रोसेस है जो Windows के
सारे ऑथेंटिकेशंस से रिलेटेड जो भी चीजें
हैं उनको हैंडल करती है। और जब भी कोई
यूजर लॉगिन करता है तो एलsस क्या करता है
कि अपनी मेमोरी के अंदर जो Windows के जो
पासवर्ड्स हैं जो भी पासवर्ड्स है यूजरनेम
और पासवर्ड्स है उसके जो पासवर्ड्स के जो
हैश है उनको क्या करता है? कैचे की फॉर्म
में स्टोर कर लेता है। और जो मिमी कैच
क्या करता है? mm कैच इस एलs.ex प्रोसेस
के साथ क्या करता है? इंटैक्ट करता है और
इसके कैचे मेमोरी से क्या करता है वह उन
पासवर्ड्स को उन हैशेस को डंप कर लेता है
उन पासवर्ड्स को उन हैसेस को क्या कर लेता
है डंप कर लेता है और जो मिमी कैच है आप
mic को दो तरीके से यूज़ कर सकते हो एक तो
तरीका है प्री कंपाइल डॉट exc फाइल आती है
जो आपके किसके अंदर है
जो आपका जो काली लinक्स है इसमें बाय
डिफॉल्ट आती है जब आप नई स्क्रीन करोगे
न्यू टैब ओपन करोगे मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं और जैसे जैसे आप क्या करोगे यहां पर
लिखोगे मिमी कैच मिमी कैच गाइड गाली के
अभी लेटेस्ट वर्जन में आता है तो यहां पर
यूजर सॉरी ओके
यूजर शेयर Windows रिसोर्सेज mix यहां पर
क्या है Windows 30 बिट 2 बिट और 64 बिट
के लिए यहां पर exc mm exc क्या होती है
आपके देखने को मिलती है यह आपके काली
लinक्स के अंदर अवेलेबल्स है जो आप क्या
कर सकते हो अपनी Windows मशीन के अंदर
ट्रांसफर करके के क्या कर सकते हो? रन
करके देख सकते हो। दूसरा क्या है कि अगर
आपने टारगेट मशीन के ऊपर जो एक्सेस लिया
है जो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव एक्सेस लिया है अगर
वह कौन सा है? इंटरप्रिटर सेशन है तो
उसमें क्या है कि एमएसएफ के अंदर एक केवी
मॉड्यूल्स है। वो मॉड्यूल क्या करता है?
वो सेम फंक्शनैलिटी प्रोवाइड करता है मिमी
कैड्स की जिसके थ्रू आप क्या कर सकते हो?
मटरप्रिंटर वर्जन में भी आप mmad यूज कर
सकते हो। जहां पर आपको फिजिकली वो अपलोड
करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ती। लेकिन सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट बात आपके लिए यह है कि सबसे
चीज इंपॉर्टेंट चीज आपको ध्यान में रखनी
है कि जो मिमीड्स है मिमीड्स को यूज़ करने
के लिए आपके पास क्या होने चाहिए?
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव लेवल के प्लेजेस होने
चाहिए या आपके पास हाईएस्ट लेवल के
प्रिवजेस होने चाहिए। जो हाई इंटीग्रिटी
लेवल के प्लेजेस होने चाहिए या सिस्टम
एक्सेस बोल सकते हो। क्यों? क्योंकि जो
एलसा जो प्रोसेस है जो आपके एलसा प्रोसेस
है इसको एक्सेस करने के लिए या इसको रीड
करने के लिए के लिए आपको एडमिन एक्सेस
चाहिए। कोई भी नॉर्मल यूजर इसको एक्सेस
नहीं कर सकता। समझ में आ गया? मिमीज क्या
होता है? किसके द्वारा डेवलप किया गया है?
और यह
क्या-क्या काम करता है? शायद यह चीजें
सबको समझ में आ गई होगी।
यह चीज सबको समझ में आई। किसी को डाउट है
मिमी कैच के अंदर?
तो बेसिकली हम क्या कह सकते हैं कि मिicज
एक पावरफुल टूल है जो एलसास जो प्रोसेस है
उसकी मेमोरी से पासवर्ड्स हैज़ और जो करबस
की जो टिकट्स है उनको क्या करता है फैच
करता है एक्सट्रैक्ट करता है और उसके बाद
आपको स्क्रीन पे शो कर देता है और इसको
एक्सेस करने के लिए इस इस टूल को चलाने के
लिए आपको एडमिन या सिस्टम लेवल के प्लेजेस
मैंडेटरी हैं। यह चीज़ सबको आई थिंक सबको
क्लियर है यह चीज़। किसी को इसमें कोई डाउट
नहीं है। तो, इसको आप अभी मुझे यह बताओ कि
मेरे पास जो एक्सेस मिला है, वह एक्सेस
कौन सा है? मेरा जो एक्सेस है, वह एक्सेस
मेरा है यह एक्सेस है मेरे पास। सेल
एक्सेस है। जब मेरे पास सेल एक्सेस है और
जो मेरा mics.xe फाइल है, वह कहां पर है?
mic.x फाइल मेरे यहां पर है या मैं बोलूं
तो मेरे डेस्कटॉप पर अवेलेबल है। मैं सीडी
करता हूं और cd डेस्कटॉप करता हूं मैं
क्योंकि मैं ऑलरेडी आपके लिए पहले से
निकाल रखा है। यह मेरा mik.exe फाइल है।
mik.exe फाइल। तो मुझे यह बताओ कि मैं
इसको कैसे यहां पर लेके आ सकता हूं अपने
इस Windows मशीन के अंदर। यह चीज आप लोग
मुझे बताओगे या नहीं बताओगे? मुझे यह बताओ
आप लोग सबसे पहले।
कैसे मैं ले आ सकता हूं? कैसे मुझे यह
बताओ।
कैसे? जल्दी से टाइप करो। टाइम नहीं है आप
लोगों के पास। सिंपल से सॉल्यूशन है। उसके
लिए आपको क्या करना है? Python सर्वर रन
करना है। Python 3 hfन m http
डॉट सर्वर पोर्ट नंबर 80 पर क्योंकि यहां
पर जो भी फाइल हो सारी होस्ट हो जाएंगी
यहां पर mmadh.exc
और हम क्या करेंगे अभी Windows के अंदर एक
यूटिलिटी होती है जिसका हम यूज़ कर सकते
हैं। कैसे? देखो वह यूटिलिटी क्या है? मैं
आपको पहले बता चुका हूं कि फाइल ट्रांसफर
सेक्शन के अंदर नहीं पता तो आपको रिवीजन
हो जाएगा आज का रिवीजन में वह क्या है
यूटिलिटी आपकी शर्ट यूटिल सर्ट यूटिल उसके
बाद आप देखोगे यहां पर मैं आपको हटा देता
हूं यह ऊपर सर्ट यूटिल और उसके अलावा हफन
यूआरएल
यूआरएल कैचे उसके बाद हफन एफ उसके बाद
http
उसके बाद हमारा किसका IPपी एड्रेस यह IP
एड्रेस यह वाला 192.168.130
डॉट क्योंकि यह हमारा लोकल सर्वर है इसके
लिए तो हम यहां पर क्या कर रहे हैं? अभी
पेस्ट कर देंगे। उसके बाद जिस फाइल को
हमें एक्सेस करना है उस फाइल का एक्सेस
क्या है? मिमी कैज मिमी
exc mm कैज
उसके अलावा कहां पर मुझे करना अभी एक और
प्रॉब्लम है एक और प्रॉब्लम स्टार्ट होगी
कि मैं यहां पर नहीं कर सकता विंडोज
सिस्टम 32 के अंदर क्योंकि
यहां पर आपको परमिशंस होगी ही नहीं तो एक
काम करते हैं अभी इसके लिए हम इसको क्या
करते हैं अभी के लिए हम इसको कॉपी करते
हैं से कॉपी सेक्शन और इसको मैं अभी बंद
कर देता हूं उसके उसके लिए हम क्या करने
वाले हैं अभी? उसके लिए हम करने वाले हैं
कि हमें एक टैप डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करनी
पड़ेगी। तो हम सीडी
सी डायरेक्टरी के अंदर रूट डायरेक्टर के
अंदर चलते हैं।
हिट एंटर और अगर डीआईआर करेंगे यहां पर
आपको टाइम डायरेक्टरी देखने को नहीं
मिलेगी। तो देखो एक फ्लैग यहां पर हमें
मिल गया। फ्लैग 1txt के अंदर तो हम क्या
करते हैं? एमके डी आईआर उसके अलावा मेरे
पास क्या है? टेंप डायरेक्टरी टेम
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर सीडी चेंज डायरेक्टरी
टेम उसके अलावा अब हम कंट्रोल शिफ्ट वी
हमने यहां पर किया उसके बाद मिमी कैच
मिमी कैच डॉट ईएक्स और हिट एंटर कर दिया
और इट विल टेक टाइम और यहां पर हमारी फाइल
ट्रांसफर हो जाएगी। सबको पता चल गया कि
फाइल ट्रांसफर कैसे होती है। लो Windows
आप Linux से Windows पर एवरीवन अगर पता चल
गया सबको यह देखिए अगर हम डीआईआर करते हैं
यह रहा फाइल ट्रांसफर होगी मिशx इसको रन
कैसे करेंगे डॉट बैकवर्ड स्लश mics exc
यह रहा और हिट एंटर करते हैं। लो हमारा
मिicड चल पड़ा। अब मिमीज में बहुत सारी
कमांड्स होती हैं जो आपको आर्टिकल्स में
देखने को मिलेगी। काफी डिटेल्स में वो
कमांड्स आपको प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा। किस
कमांड किस पर्पस से यूज़ किया जाता होगा वो
सारी चीज़ मैं आपको बता दूंगा। तो सबसे
पहले हम वर्जन चेक कर सकते हैं। वर्जन चेक
करने के लिए जो हमारी कमांड होगी वो हो
सकती है आपकी
स्टैंडर्ड
डबल कॉलन। उसके बाद हम लिखेंगे वर्जन।
हिट एंटर किए। यह हमारा mich का वर्जन
2.2.
Windows का एंटी 6.1 यूज किया जा रहा है।
यह आपको पता चल गया। उसके अलावा एक अब हम
क्या करते हैं?
प्रिविलेज पी आर आई पी एल प्रिविलेज उसके
बाद डबल कॉलन।
उसके बाद डीबग
हिटच एंटर यह रहा। कोई नहीं है। यह एरर आ
रही है इस केस में। अदरवाइज यहां पर आपको
क्या आएगा? यह कोड मिलेगा और ओके में
देखने को मिलेगा। बट अभी भी क्या है कि
इसको ज्यादा चिंता करने की जरूरत नहीं
क्योंकि नेक्स्ट स्टेप आपको परफॉर्म करके
देखना ही चाहिए कि क्या मैं प्रिविलजेस
लिस्ट कर पा रहा हूं नहीं कर पा रहा हूं।
एक काम करते हैं अभी
प्रिविलेज
लिस्ट देखेंगे। तो यहां पर देखोगे कि यहां
पर मॉड्यूल प्लीज है प्लीज मॉड्यूल आस्क
डीबक प्रिलजेस आस्क लोड ड्राइवर प्लीज
आस्क सिक्योरिटी प्रिविलेज आस्क टीसीबी
बैकअप रिस्टोर प्लेज एनवायरमेंट प्रिवेज
आईडी इसके अभी इससे मुझे कोई मतलब नहीं
मुझे क्या करना है डंप करना है तो मैं
क्या कहता हूं अभी मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा
कौन-कौन सी कमांड यूज़ की जाती है एक एक
कमांड होती है टोकन
टोकंस के अंदर होती है हमारी हु एम आई
अपना टोकन देखने के लिए यह भी देख सकते
हो। यह मेरा प्रोसेस का टोकन है। एंटी
अथॉरिटी सिस्टम्स है। यहां पर आपको देखने
को मिलेगा। थ्रेड टोकंस नो टोकंस और उसके
अलावा अभी हम डंप करते हैं। एलएसए डंप
एलएसए डंप उसके बाद सेम डेटाबेस से हम डंप
करते हैं और देखते हैं यहां पर हमें क्या
देखने को मिलता है। चलो यहां पर हमें
देखने को मिल गया। गुड। हमें क्या देखने
को मिला? यह रहा। एक तो डोमेन नेम sिस की
मैंने आपको बताया था ना कि एंटी एलएम#श
मेक और की का यूज किया जाता है उसको
प्रोटेक्ट करने के लिए sिस की यहां पर sिस
की आपको हैश फॉर्म में मिल गई है उसके बाद
देखो यूजर या यह रहा आपका यूजर और उसका
एंटी एल एसएम एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का एंटी एल
एस यूजर कॉपी
यहां पर हम पेस्ट कर लेते हैं क्योंकि काम
की चीज है हमारे लिए
पेस्ट कर लिया उसके अलावा एक और यूजर हमें
मिला तो चलिए हमें एक और यूजर मिला कौन सा
जोन तो दो दो यूज़र्स और उनके एंटीएलम है
सब हमें मिल गए हमें मिल गए तो चलिए बहुत
अच्छी बात है
पेस्ट हो गया पेस्ट दो चीजें हमें देखने
को मिल गई तो अभी ये चीज तो हमें देखने को
मिल गई एक और कमांड होती है आप जो चेक कर
सकते हो एलएस
ओके एलएसए डंप
सीक्रेट्स
सीक्रेट्स हिट एंटर यह देखो इसमें आपको
क्या देखने को मिल रहा है सेम है
डिफॉल्ट पासवर्ड ऑल्ट टीxt ये रहा नथिंग
नथिंग एल्स कुछ खास इसमें है नहीं तो कोई
नहीं है तो उसके अलावा एक और चीज होती है
सिक्योर एलएसए एस ई के
यू आर सिक्योर एलएसए
उसके बाद लॉग ऑन पासवर्ड्स यह सारी इसकी
चीटशीट मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा। लॉग
ऑन सबको चीटशीट चाहिए नहीं चाहिए बताओ।
लॉग ऑन पासवर्ड्स
यह रहा। तो काफी डिटेल्स में यहां पे यहां
पर एंटर देखने को मिल रही है। यह देखो
पीसी पीसी ओके सीक्रेट पास सीक्रेट
डिफॉल्ट पासवर्ड डीपीआई एंड नाउ इसके अंदर
कुछ नहीं है। सिक्योर लॉग ऑन पासवर्ड ये
रहा। था सर्विस फॉर्म लोकल सर्विस डोमेन
एंटी अथॉरिटी लॉग ऑन टाइम सो ऑन सो उसके
बाद सर्विस फॉर्म यह यहां पर कुछ और
इंफॉर्मेशन है नहीं यह रहा पीसी वर्क
ग्रुप
यहां पर क्या देख लोगे यहां पर कुछ और खास
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है ऑलरेडी आपको एंटी अलम
हैस आपको देखने को मिल चुके हैं
बिल्कुल आपको लोगो मिल जाए तो ये चीजें
कुछ कमांड थी जो आपको पता चल गई होगी। तो
आपको पता चल गया कि एंटीएल मैसेज हमारे
पास आ गए। यह रहा आपका एंटीएलम है
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का और आपका है इसका किसका
जोन का अब मुझे एक काम कीजिए मैं एक आपको
बता दिया कि एम mmc.ex से कैसे कर सकते
हैं? लेकिन एक और चीज है। अभी मैं इसको
एग्जिट कर देता हूं। अगर मेरे पास
मटरप्रेट सेशन है तो उस केस में कैसे
करूंगा? फॉर एग्जांपल्स अभी मैं आपको शो
करूं कि पहली बात तो मुझे यह बताओ कि यहां
से मेरे पास सेल है। सेल से मटरप्रेटर
सेशन में कैसे कन्वर्ट करूं? सेल से
मटरप्रेटर सेशन में हम कैसे जा सकते हैं?
इज देयर एनीवे कोई तरीका है जाने का? कोई
भी तरीका?
कोई भी तरीका है?
बताओ।
कोई तरीका नहीं है।
एक काम करते हैं इसको बैकग्राउंड में चलते
हैं। बिल्कुल कंट्रोल Z
कंट्रोल Z यस हम बैकग्राउंड रख रहे हैं।
अब एक ऑप्शन होता है। एक मॉड्यूल होता है
सर्च
सेल टू मीटर ऑपरेटर। पैदल गैस सेल टू मीटर
प्रिंटर
हिट एंटर मिल गया हम इसको यूज़ करेंगे
और उसके बाद ऑप्शंस को चेक करेंगे कौन-कौन
से ऑप्शंस चाहिए ऑप्शंस में हमें
क्या-क्या चाहिए एक काम करते हैं मैं इसको
बंद कर देता हूं
ओके ऑप्शंस में आपको ओनली ओके के सेल टू
इंटरप्रेटर सेशंस चाहिए आपको ओनली और
सेशंस की इंफॉर्मेशन कैसे देख सकते हो आप
सेशंस चेक करोगे अब मेरे पास कौन से सेशन
है अभी एक्टिव सेशन मेरा कौन सा है सेशन
नंबर थ्री है यह मेरा एक्टिव सेशन है तो
मैं क्या करने वाला हूं मैं यूज़ करने वाला
हूं कैसे हम यूज़ करेंगे सेट
सेट
सेशन
उसके बाद
थ्री हिट एंटर देन उसके बाद हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? इसको रन कर देंगे। सीधा इसको हम
रन कर देंगे। जैसे इसको रन करेंगे तो हमें
मीटर प्रिटर सेशन मिल जाएगा।
गाइज मजा आ रहा है? इट विल टेक टाइम।
सबको मजा आ रहा है बताओ।
थोड़ा सा टाइम लगेगा एंड देखिए हिट एंटर
कर दिया और हम सेशंस को चेक करते हैं।
सेशंस अभी सेशंस हमारा एक्टिव नहीं हुआ
है। इट विल टेक टाइम।
अभी तक हमारा सेशन आया नहीं है। आ जाएगा
यह कोई इशू नहीं है।
नहीं नहीं थ्री नहीं है। थ्री नहीं है।
थ्री नहीं है।
थ्री तो आप ऑलरेडी यूज कर रहे हो। तो एक
बार फिर से हम रन करते हैं। इसको ऑप्शन को
चेक करते हैं एक बार फिर से। ऑप्शंस हमारे
सब कुछ सेट है और हम इसको रन करते हैं।
मनीष क्लास एंड होने वाला है। यू आर यह
अभी अभी अभी स्टार्ट हो गया। सेशन फोर ओपन
नाउ अभी चेक करते हैं हम
सेशंस यस सेशन फोर आ गया अभी हम यूज़ करने
वाले हैं सेशन फोर हिट एंटर किया
सेशंस फोर हमारे पास मीटर प्रस सेशन आ गया
क्लियर करते हैं यह देखो
चलो तो अभी हम एक काम करते हैं यहां पर
चेक करते हैं कि
अपना एक मॉड्यूल सेम वही हु एम आई
यार हु एम आई नहीं होस्ट नेम
ओके
ओके हेल्प देख लेते हैं यार हेल्प कमांड
अभी हम यूज़ कर रहे हैं गेट यूआईडी
गेट यूआईडी एंटी अथॉरिटी सिस्टम चलो हम ये
यूज़ करते हैं मॉड्यूल लोड की हुई
ये रहा मॉड्यूल लोड किया और जैसे हम इसको
लोड कर लेंगे
उसके बाद आप चेक कर सकते हो हेल्प फाइल
सेम है यह सेम है देखो हेल्प फाइल में आप
क्रेडेंशियल सोल रिट्रीव ऑल क्रेडेंशियल्स
करबस क्रेडेंशियल्स को रिट्रीव कर सकते हो
उसके बाद देखोगे
डंप एलएसए सेम डेटाबेस एलएसए सीक्रेट सेम
चीज है मैं अभी क्या क्या करने वाला हूं
यह वाला
क्रेडेंशियल्स अंडरस्कोर ऑल हिट एंटर देखो
यहां पर क्या मिला हुआ यहां पर मुझे कुछ
नहीं मिला अभी मैं एलएस डम इसको यूज़ यूज़
करने वाला हूं। कॉपी एंड पेस्ट सेम चीज है
बट थोड़ा मॉड्यूल है। देखो ये रहा सेम
इनेशन मिले एडमिन और ज़न। तो इस तरीके से
आप क्या है? सेम तरीके से इन ऑप्शंस का
यूज़ कर सकते हो। किसके अंदर? KV मॉड्यूल्स
के अंदर। सेम है मिड्स का। यह मटर प्रिटर
सेशन के अंदर मॉड्यूल्स है। मीटर प्रिटर
जो एमएमएसएफ कंसोल है जो मीटर प्रिटर है
उसके अंदर यह आपको मिमिक्स की फंक्शनैलिटी
देखने को मिल रही है। और अदरवाइज आप कहां
पर देख दूसरा कहां पर देख सकते थे आप?
दूसरा देख सकते थे आप किसके अंदर?
Windows के अंदर डॉट एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल
के अंदर। तो, आई होप कि आज का सेशन मैं
कंप्लीट नहीं कर पाया। हाउ टू फाइंड
एक्टिव सेशंस? दीज़ आर द एक्टिव सेशंस
ब्रो। यह रहा। अगर हम एक काम करते हैं।
मैं इसको अभी कंट्रोल Z कर देता हूं।
यस कर दिया। तो जब आप एक कमांड यूज़ करोगे
बेटे। यह रहा
सेशंस यह रहा। तो यहां पे ये सारे एक्टिव
सेशंस हैं। तीनों एक्टिव सेशंस हैं। मैं
अगर सेशंस टू को शिफ्ट करता हूं। सेशंस टू
यह मिल गया। सेशन टू भी मेरा ओपन हो गया।
सेशन थ्री भी मेरा ओपन हो रहा है। सेशन
फोर भी मेरा ओपन हो रहा है। समझ में आ गई
बात?
समझ में आ गया
यहां तक सबको चीजें समझ में आई
स्टूडेंट्स
बच्चों सबको समझ में आया
तो जल्दी से चैट में यस या नो बताएं सबको
यहां तक सारी चीजें सबको क्लियर है यस या
नो जल्दी से बताओ जितने भी स्टूडेंट्स हैं
जल्दी से यस या नो आंसर बताइए यहां तक
सबको क्लियर क्लियर है? फटाफट जल्दी से
जल्दी-जल्दी बताओ।
यस। ओके। लेट आए थे। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है। एक बार सेशन को देखिए। अभी सेशन
कंप्लीट नहीं हुआ। प्रॉब्लम यह है कि आज
सेशन इतना ही कर पाएंगे।
क्योंकि पास द हैश जो अटैक्स है अभी तक
हमने डिस्कस तक नहीं किया क्योंकि हमारी
जो लैब्स थी वो काफी स्लो चल रही थी तो
क्योंकि इतना इस लैब्स को हमने सॉल्व कर
लिया इस लेवल तक हम लेकर गए कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है तो
कल फिर क्लास होगी सेम टॉपिक पे पास द हैश
अटैक वहां पर हम देखेंगे कि एक्चुअल में
पास द हैश अटैक होता क्या है कैसे परफॉर्म
किया जाता है और फर्दर इसको कंटिन्यू
करेंगे और विद इन वन हावर सेशन को कंप्लीट
कर देंगे। कल भी क्लास 53 आपकी होगी।
ओके एवरीवन?
तो ओके। तो आज का सेशन यहीं पे एंड
करेंगे। अगर किसी को कोई भी डाउट है
रिलेटेड टू द सेशन आज के सेशन से रिलेटेड
या पहले वाले सेशन से रिलेटेड तो वह आप
मुझसे पूछ सकते हो। अदरवाइज हम आज सेशन को
एंड करेंगे और इसका पार्ट टू कल लेकर
आएंगे और पार्ट टू में हम फिर से कंप्लीट
डिस्कशन करेंगे क्योंकि थोड़ा सा मुझे
लगता है कि मैं चीजें कुछ कहीं पर जल्दी
जल्दबाजी में डिलीवर कर दी होगी। कहीं पर
हमारी टाइम स्टार्टिंग की जो 20 मिनट थी
वह टोटल वेस्टेज ऑफ टाइम हो गया।
इसको हम कंटिन्यू करेंगे। कल भी लेंगे।
ओके? इस पर सेशन बैक टू बैक कल 100% कल इस
पे लेंगे और इसको हम कंप्लीट करेंगे
क्योंकि टॉपिक हमने शुरू किया है। इस पर
गैप नहीं रख सकते।
यह पूछिए
डायनेमिक
गुड नाइट।
तो नोट्स मैं आपको बता तो रहा हूं। आपको
फिर से बता देता हूं मैं। मैं आप लोगों के
लिए आर्टिकल्स लिखता हूं। यह आर्टिकल्स
हैं। यह देखो। यह सारे आर्टिकल्स हैं। यह
मैंने लिखे हैं। जितने भी सेशंस अभी सारे
के नहीं है। लेकिन अभी रिसेंटली मैंने आप
लोगों के लिए स्टार्ट किया है। नोट्स
डिलीवर करने का नया तरीका। यह देखो
बायपासिंग यूएससी पार्ट वन फाइनल पार्ट
इसके चार आर्टिकल्स हैं। यह देखो सारे
आर्टिकल्स मेरे द्वारा लिखे गए हैं। यह
सारे के सारे आर्टिकल्स हैं। आप देख सकते
हो और जो लेटेस्ट जो आर्टिकल्स हैं ये रहे
सारे। मैं आपको एक आर्टिकल शेयर कर रहा
हूं जिससे आप दूसरे आर्टिकल्स तक पहुंच
जाओगे। तो जल्दी से इन आर्टिकल्स को
देखिए। मैं आपको उसी से शेयर कर रहा हूं।
जाके आप यहां से इनको फॉलो कर सकते हो। और
आपकी मर्जी है। आपको कोई कमेंट भेजना है,
कमेंट भेज सकते हो या आप को
कोई भी रिव्यू देना है या आपको शेयर करना
है किसी के साथ या आप चाहते हो कि हमें
अपडेट मिलता रहे आर्टिकल्स के थ्रू भी तो
वह भी आप लोग पढ़ सकते हो। ओके?
या किसी के साथ शेयर कर सकते हो।
सब्सक्राइब कर सकते हो। ईमेल नोटिफिकेशन
तो एक काम करते हैं फिर सेशन में अगर आपका
कोई भी
linp आप यूज़ नहीं कर सकते linp linux के
लिए होता है बेटा और linux का केस अभी तक
मैंने बताया नहीं है linx का केस आएगा
linp जिस पे आप यूज़ नहीं कर सकते आप विनज
यूज़ कर सकते हो Windows के केस में लिन
पेज इसके लिए नहीं है
चलो फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं। अगर आपका
कोई भी डाउट नहीं है तो।
यस विन का भी पर्पस अलग है। विनज आप यूज़
कर सकते हो। विन आपको बहुत सारी चीजें
बताती है। Windows में बहुत सारे ऐसे
टूल्स अवेलेबल्स हैं जो आप यूज़ कर सकते
हो। बट कोई बता मैं हर एक चीज को वन बाय
वन चीज आपको बता रहा हूं।
चलिए फिर गुड नाइट। बाय-ब टेक केयर एंड सी
यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन गाइस। नेक्स्ट सेशन
में मिलते हैं जल्दी। नेक्स्ट सेशन कल ही
होगा। 100% कल होगा। मैं आपको बता दिया।
कल ही के लिए आपका शेड्यूल होगा। नेक्स्ट
सेशन भी पार्ट टू क्योंकि इसको कंप्लीट
करते हैं। तो चलिए बाय-ब गुड नाइट एंड सी
यू फॉर टुमारो।